okay so we're down to our last speaker
of the day and we have saved the best
for last uh we're talking about the
chief data officer of cerice group uh
extremely conscientious guy uh was
formerly known as goo Joe uh and and a
little known fact even though he lives
in Florida he still keeps his house at
83 degrees every single day of the year
ladies and gentlemen Mr Joe blanket
all right let's go so once again my name
is Je blanket ship CDO of cerice um
going to talk to you today about smart
cities and the project we did over on
the American victory
ship um so we're going to go over the
fundamentals of smart environments um
once again the name smart cities is kind
of deceiving but I want to make sure we
go over the basics of what a smart
environment is kind of go to a
subclassification of smart Maritime
systems and then kind of go into the
case study on what we did on the
American victory ship in terms of
building out our Maritime lab so what is
a smart environment essentially it's a
collection of sensors um that represents
a space um through collections of data
and kind of storing that on several
different types of computational
elements now once again the key aspect
of these environments is to make sure
that you're capturing critical features
of the physical and human spaces um in a
way that you want to quantify into a
data format that then gets stored
somewhere that helps guide some level
activity um for decision- making and
some kind of metric for value of
outcomes both operationally and
strategically within those
environments now the data collected from
these sensors can be uh mobilized in a
number of ways simulations automation
predictive modeling um and there are
several different architectural forms
that you can Implement these in from
local to Global you have your
smartphones there are Smart Homes smart
buildings that have floor to floor
integration those are constitute larger
areas of smart cities smart ports are
part of that so these things are
becoming more and more interconnected
both in terms of devices and data um
from you know cities to International so
um it's pretty exciting time to be
looking at these kind of
systems um these things are implemented
um in terms of
just based on what kind of critical
outcomes the Stak holders and people
inside the environment want to elicit
strategically and operationally so from
the physical aspects of the environment
itself to the human places and
activities going inside these physical
environments to the Cyber um
infrastructure and devices that kind of
connect and overlap and collect on all
those um different processes and states
that exist inside of a city a home Etc
so the requirements that are constituted
up front kind of Drive
how the smart smart environment kind of
manifest over time so everything from
the sensors and actuators that you
select have to be scoped within what you
want to collect inside that environment
and only how you want to monitor things
and ultimate what you want to model
based on the data that you get from
these sensors all has to stem from a
clear idea and guidance on what exactly
you want your digital representation of
that environment to
be now this all requires a lot of
research and clear observation on
exactly what is going on inside the
environment both from a physical and a
human aspect and then ultimately use
that to drive good engineering decisions
on exactly how you're going to build and
deploy the smart environment over time
and in this case scale really does
matter um in terms of like a home maybe
not so much maybe you have set
activities but as you scale up these
things into bigger and bigger
assemblages of both sensor and data you
have to take into account different kind
of form factors how they overlap with
one each other inside of these larger
data and system architectures and
ultimately how you're going to Stage the
deployments of these things to make sure
that longitudinally the data you're
collecting is going to represent the
people and processes and ultimately the
decisions you're going to be making with
the data over
time now once again there are a lot of
considerations and challenges with
deploying these systems um first is PRI
regulation so regulation and policy
especially in the US you have FCC in
terms of the hardware considerations you
want to make sure that not flooding or
overlapping with any already licensed or
leased signals formats and also you want
to make sure that you're not conflicting
with any other types of devices that
aren't allowed to be in those kind of
bands and
spectrums but probably more importantly
than the hardware and the software
aspect of this thing is the educational
component of it um in a lot of these
smart City scenarios there are a lot of
communities and population areas where
people are apprehensive about being
monitored 24/7 by Smart City or smart
environment infrastructure structure
this requires the people that want to
deploy these kind of systems to engage
in a lot of Outreach toensure that
people that are key stakeholders people
that are going to be your Champions
Community leaders are going to be aware
of the benefit to them of what these
systems are going to be what the
ultimate value you're going to be
listing for yourself and how that is in
their best interest to do so otherwise
you encounter stuff like digital divide
and red lining where communities end up
getting kind of surveilled in their own
like little Tac Technical panopticon and
you want to kind of avoid that because
you run the risk of deploying a smart
environment with the intention to
collect a certain type of behavior or to
optimize certain types of operations in
the environment but because of the
manner that you deployed it the people
now act differently they ched their
patterns of life and now what you're
collecting with that smart environment
isn't at all what you intended to model
upfront so making sure that those people
have access to information making sure
they're part of the decision-making
process for deploying that environment
will help kind of avoid those kind of
deterministic risks that you engage with
when implementing these kind of systems
at
scale so ceris did a lot of research
upfront to make sure that we kind of
understood how to go about implementing
these systems from scratch and we looked
at two cities in terms of their process
in deploying kind of smart environments
Smart City infrastructures the first was
the city of Pittsburgh um in the
Allentown area of Pittsburgh there was a
free internet um
Access Wi-Fi signal called pit mesh um
it was deployed using ubiquity hardware
and it essentially allowed people that
could not afford access or persistent
access to Internet to have free internet
access for education employment and to
provide other opportunities for them to
get access to that over time pit mesh
evolved into a 501c3 nonprofit called
metamesh which is a wide area internet
service provider service so instead of
just having free Wi-Fi they now have
very fast point-to-point
um internet and they have made it to
where you can apply for a system they'll
send you the commodity Hardware to link
up to their white area internet service
provider Network and then you have free
internet like that and it's now a
service to the broader Pittsburgh area
so a very good successful story there
array of things in Chicago was a bit
different that was a waggle based iot
infrastructure for doing mainly
Metropolitan environmental monitoring
and research um mostly around
meteorology and transportation
now that effort by the University of
Chicago and with the city of Chicago was
really good because they started out by
taking that data directly from those
devices with a little bit ETL and then
dumping it right onto the city's data
portal so everybody had access to that
data that later got superseded by Sage
Continuum so using the same wagle
architecture they were able to mobilize
a system format and a data format that
cities all around the world to take copy
and in their own cities so not only does
Chicago now have a kind of improved
standard for doing these kind of iot
projects but cities all around the world
can share the same type of data with the
same formatting kind of exchange other
things in an international manner which
is really really cool but the key
takeaway from both of these engagements
was that especially from metamesh they
were very clear that if you're going to
be deploying a smart environment or
doing anything with Smart Systems period
that the people who these systems are be
interacting with the most have to
understand why it's in their space why
it benefits them and ultimately what the
data that is going to be collected there
represents of them so they don't feel
threatened or feel prone to change their
behaviors within those environments
so that brings us to Smart Maritime
systems so smart Maritime systems in our
case what we did with smart ports we
focused on the fact that these are
environments that are meant to
facilitate transportation from Maritime
land land to Maritime and to accelerate
Maritime trade and commerce flows you
you want to get Commodities out of the
port you want get quantities into the
port you want to get them out of the
port environment to go to whoever vendor
is paying for that stuff then vice versa
so there are a lot of major examples
and is no surprise to anybody Port
Authorities aren't really keen on
letting you just walk around a port and
asking questions about all their stuff
works so a lot of this was done with
gray literature and with with whatever
Publications were done on these kind of
environments but from what you could
tell um some of the leading examples
like Port of Hamburg and Port of ANP are
really focused on two major things which
was op optimization of operations and
management and also Energy Efficiency in
fact Energy Efficiency was kind of a
trend of along all smart smart ports
because operating costs fuel energy St
like that those are major impacts to
their their overall operational budget
so in a lot of cases smart environments
are a cost savings measures but B also
just process optimization standards um
the port Ching down in China they
specifically implemented their 5G system
because of of the flows going in and out
of their ports was so volumous that they
really had to optimize operational
speeds and acceleration with precision
and accuracy to make sure they knew
where every container was going into
which ships so that ships don't get
delayed out of port or coming into Port
so not just you know Energy Efficiency
but obviously accelerating things as
fast as possible to make sure they're
maintaining op optimal operational Pace
was
critical and going on pretty okay got 10
minutes um so smart Maritime
environments they're they're really cool
interstitial um smart environments
because they kind of bridge Maritime and
they kind of go from the peripher of a
smart City directly into a smart City a
lot of times Urban environments kind of
coincide with Maritime environment so
there's a correlation there but they
don't have to but when you're looking at
smart Maritime systems you often are
looking at Smart City environments that
overlap with it as well as the
transportation infrastructure so there's
at least two coinciding smart
infrastructures that go with
smart Maritime systems now once again
there's also the regulatory bridging
that goes on there as well you have
different Flag ships from different
nations you have different policies in
terms of what Commodities go in and out
of which ports depending what nations
they are where they're coming from where
they're going to and then also at local
law enforcement Port Authority BHS stuff
like that in the US like everybody has a
certain legal purview everybody has to
observe certain practices inside these
environments so understanding that as
part of your model even though your
model is mostly focused on you know
monitor energy here monitor person
activity over here monitor automation
over
here the what is going on with those
processes matters to the people that
want to mobilize the data coming off
those systems to make decisions on what
they're going to do how they're going to
do it and who they have to report to and
in order to ensure that those things are
done as securely as
possible so but there's a lot of art
possible there so when you're collecting
and simulating these kind of
environments there's a lot of potential
for automation tracking of both vessel
the Commodities the human labor assets
going on there but then as I pointed out
with all the examples you know
operations management and Energy
Efficiency is also one of those things
that's you know it's cost effective but
also accelerates operational cost and
increases more value for them over time
so pretty cool but once again there are
a lot of challenges to build up these
smart Port environments they are
extremely expensive like very very
expensive um the examples in China and
Europe you know those are multi-million
dollar sometimes reaching on billion-
dollar processes um they had to spend a
lot of money to get policy and
regulations in place to allow for
certain practices to occur to enable the
smart system deployments and
installations in a way that was really
secure and helped um inform labor
resources and people on the ground
exactly how these environments were
going to change around them and how that
would affect them spefically and how
they then adjusted labor practices to
accommodate those new systems so pretty
interesting stuff so that brings us to
service group and what we did over in
the Channel Side area with the American
victory ship so the goal with that lab
was to build a an environment for smart
Maritime and smart Port research we
needed something that was modular could
be adapted to a lot of different
scenarios using very adaptable hardware
and software solutions to make a system
that was not just reproducible for any
customer but that could be trainable to
a standard that they they could then go
and take that system and train other
people with it so it was a really
interesting challenge um and we kind of
had to focus in on the scale and the
applicability of that system pretty
quickly so the first part of the
solution was site selection so the
American fer ship was a really good
solution even though I had some
reservations about initially it was a
really good solution for a lot of
reasons the first one is that if you're
on top of a big ship and you have a
telescopic Mass it gives you a lot of
height and elevation right off the bat
in the port environment which means that
your signal layer has a lot better line
of sight with the devices that going be
around you in that smart environment so
even though there's a lot of signal syns
and challenges there you do have a lot
of opportunity to put a lot of devices
in a fairly high density to actually
meet the simulations they be doing later
another part of it is that it does give
you a ship Deport relationship to
actually model inside of your systems as
you're going along so the ship the
internals of the ship the deck itself
that can be replete with sensors the
pork can be have sensors and then you
can monitor the interactions between
those so that's another good one another
aspect of it is that the Victor ship
helped us understand how deploying
things on a ship itself in terms of
smart environment in smart Maritime
sensors themselves can be a challenge so
instead of going with a landbased system
in the port environment around it we
chose to go with kind of one of the
more difficult but more the realistic
deployment scenarios that might occur
with these kind of systems and then last
not but not least um deploying it in
this environment allowed us to extend
Scale based modeling so you're in a
you're on a ship that's in a port that
Port is now extended into a smart City
very close to it so you get to do
modeling that's based on those different
scales of effect as well so really
really cool conception and did a lot of
work to make sure that was done
correctly um commercial off the shelf
technology that was another thing we
want to make sure that people could just
have a phone or laptop go anywhere and
just start buying pieces of this model
put it together on their own and then
deploy scenarios in Hardware that best
match their expect ation for how they
want to deploy a system of their own so
iot devices of pretty standard formats
um signals formats that could have those
devices sit on those networks and then
making sure that these things could be
deployed and function in a variety of
different environments um obviously
Maritime environment being one of the
more difficult for anything to work
but the other thing is getting good
Community Partners we did a lot of work
upfront to make sure that we worked with
the American Victor ship and the port
authority to make sure that everybody
knew what was going on make sure they
know what we're doing when we're walking
around looking like maniacs with radios
and antennas and different stuff going
on and off ship they knew exactly who we
are and what we were doing um we also
had AWS the resources our way as well as
the ablenook team who is uh responsible
for helping us deploy the facility
itself onto the ship so a lot of good
partners a lot of good collaboration and
communication between us which made this
thing go a lot
smoother now more about the maritime lab
itself um able Nook produces very cool
modular facilities and at first I was
like this is going to be a headache you
know it's like I'm the kind of guy who
just wants to throw a tent up there and
just like we just put radios around it'd
be fine um
but the ablenook presented an
interesting scenario for me in terms of
how would you deploy a system like this
in a way that was Secure could be done
across multiple sites but then also
allow the customer to adapt it to their
needs like could scale this thing up
scale this thing down without too much
hassle but still have something that
looks like a proper lab could allow
people to work inside of it as a control
and then deploy stuff out into the
broader environment and still allow it
to be adapted to whatever scenario they
might come across and abl nook's modular
um facility model was just what we
needed you know it adapted to deploying
on the hatch it allowed us to build it
to specifications so it Blended right in
with the ship as you can see in that
lower photo with the helicopter I mean
it kind of was we were able to build it
to specification just kind of blend
right in with the ship and it still had
all the space and availability and
functionality we needed to do all the
lab based stuff in and around the ship
so it end up being a great um
choice now with the once we had the
facility and on the shift then we
started building out the signals bash
and all the stuff that we need to put
sensors on so we went with a Wi-Fi mesh
that also had lower gateways 5G
connectivity we put it onto a telescopic
Mast and made sure that we had not just
internet resources in terms of starlink
LT and we also had the 5G LTE backup as
well for internet but we also made sure
that we had cameras microphones plus
stuff on top of mas and then we also Tim
to developed a tool called Mel um that
allow us to remotely access this system
from anywhere that has a Wi-Fi signal
and do it in a secure manner so which is
another key thing to these systems as
well is to allow remote access and
remote marketing for date analysis
modeling
Etc so devices this could be a whole T
onto itself um esp32 devices I love them
they come pretty much pre-made to be
built to any kind of scenario you can
ENT transducers to it and produce any
number of sensors and actuators lit
dozens of them depending on what St you
want to and as I mentioned the Mas comes
equipped or we equipped it with um
cameras microphones also a uh focused
dish array for doing Point too and sight
to sight connectivity so you don't even
need internet to do that if you had an
auster environment where you had no
internet you can obviously connect these
things side to S side and build your own
mesh like that so build it completely
off the grid if you want to the date
architecture is very simple we used AWS
iot for a lot of the stuff however we
can deploy chirpstack if you wanted to
do an on-prem or hybrid deploy and that
integrates with AWS iot things Network
any number of different iot Cloud
resources also on site tim2 Hill
developed a dashboard for doing low code
no code um so that you can take those
iot sensor datas represent represent
them in dashboards and then also use skg
and some of the data ETL tools on site
to do all the processing you would need
without having to go outside the site if
you don't want to so lessons learned
since I have like 50 seconds um three
main challenges that we kind of
identified and would still like to work
on as we go through this environment
thing when is scale the environment
signals propagation and sensor density
is always going be a challenge in these
environments once again clear
requirements up front clear questions
about what kind of envirment You're
Building what you want to Monitor and
who the stakeholders are in terms of
what value they they want out of the
environment all kind of drive this so if
you know that and you know that the
sensor density has to be increased to
accommodate stuff like steel reinforced
concrete a metal ship fences all the
stuff that kind of sucks your signals
down in the environment you have to
build to make sure you're compensating
for all those challenges the other one
is the Environmental constraints
themselves you don't really control the
smart city so much
as once you deploy your sensors if
something happens to the transportation
infrastructure or happens to the
buildings that you're to monitor ing
then you have to redeploy certain parts
of the system so persistent monitoring
and adjustments to human-based behaviors
as well is part of this whole
development process so as you go along
you have to essentially account for the
fact that your system in the environment
is going to change and then last but not
least data volumes these sensor arrays
at volume and density produce a ton of
data so up front you have to scope and
model for the types of data and the
dimensionality you're to be getting off
these sensors and then make sure you
have the compute and storage to match
those requirements over time because it
will build up um so you need to make
sure that if you're doing Cloud you have
the budget if you're doing on Prem you
have all the resources there to store it
on Prem
and that is it all right thank you all
much